I know I listened to your podcast look I
am a huge like I said super duper fan I
have listened to these podcasts for
years so I listened to you in poverty I
yeah what do you think a post tribal ad
since you're a super band how can we how
could we be better well I think you
underestimated me a little bit maybe a
little bit I know you that's okay
that's okay a lot of people did that's
why I got to where I got and I played
that up you know I wanted people to
think that I wasn't gonna get votes at
the end but I knew that I was making
these one-on-one relationships you
didn't see most of them on the show but
I knew I was making solid relationships
with the people that were ultimately
going to make up the jury I think for me
and and when ice when you say we ender
underestimated to do part of and I it
was about sometimes freaking out having
those moments of panic and then making
maybe you know drastic moves at a time
where you think we're just cool your
jets a little bit out of watching back
now I mean you're the winner so I guess
you can't regret too much but what would
you have changed in terms of you know
well I wouldn't change anything because
it ended up working out so yeah I
definitely recognize that I made
mistakes along the way and like I said a
final tribal council I think it was my
recovery from those mistakes that was
able to get me to the win and honestly
some of the things were very public like
with my my thing with Taylor and Jay at
that tribal council where they accused
me of hiding the food and they knew that
they were doing what they needed to do
to stay in the game so when they left it
wasn't really hard feelings you know
what I mean but to everyone else they
saw it is tailored hates Adam and Jay
hates Adam and that was good for me you
know that that made people think oh he's
someone that I could go to the end with
and potentially be but what they didn't
realize is you know with those
conversations that you see with you know
where I'm telling Jay you know
afterwards like you know sorry I lied to
you and everyone's like why is he doing
all this but being straightforward and
being straight up with people I think
earned some respect from them in the end
it was a unanimous vote
it was yes that's that is the epitome of
respect yeah you know I think it'll be
interesting - now you know go back and
watch the season with that new lens and
it was certainly hard for me because I
want to defend myself throughout this
whole way but I mean I was like give it
a few weeks and and that you know the
votes will speak for themselves a little
bit about Jay because you two had there
were a lot of great dynamics on the show
this season really fun to watch what a
miserable relationship right it's like I
kept saying like kiss and get it over
when they're talking I know there was
some kind of tension there I'm guessing
it wasn't sexual there you go again
but know that tension and that love
there yeah is it still there today
absolutely yeah
Jay is a brother to me and he always
will be and we are so different in so
many ways but he is an incredible person
you know at the heart and and and we you
know we battle and we like to say like
we're Batman in the Joker and it turns
out you know I was the Joker and he was
that man but but you know there is
something very very special about our
relationship and you know he was out
there for similar reasons like he loves
his sister and his mom so much and he
would do anything for them and in the
end I think that's why he respected the
move that I had to make which was vote
him out you know I don't know that
there's ever been a pair that got along
so wasn't like loved each other so much
but that never worked together in the
game was so interesting I think students
of the game will study you - yeah in
years to come going how did that how can
those guys possibly still be friends
well one of the things that that was
central to my game that we never really
saw on the show was that I had
relationships with the other side so I
had people like Brett for example Brett
and I had a deal where he was on this
side and I was on this side and we
agreed my group my group is never gonna
target Brett and Brett's group is never
gonna talk to me and it helped me stay
out of the cross fires when my side lost
you know and so I had relationships like
that across the aisle and
it worked out now you had some obviously
some very very difficult and personal
things happening to you while you were
there you began this journey not knowing
how your mom would do and fighting
through it all and doing this for her
yeah where are you at now are you at
peace with with what you've experienced
and and where you have so you know I
said many times on the show like the
reason I was out there was to bring joy
to my family so that they could you know
watch me at home and be a part of it
with me and it didn't happen like I
imagined it would happening with us on
the couch watching together with my mom
but she lived it she really did and and
you know the reason why is actually
something I haven't mentioned but I'm
sure it's coming out now exposed
exclusive you know my my mom stopped
treatment and towards the the end of the
game you know she was gaining so much
strength by having me out there but at
the same time they knew you know she's
not undergoing treatment right now and
so they made the decision that if I were
voted out of the game then I would have
come home so in a way my mom got to play
along because she every day that I
didn't come home was another day that
she knew that I was moving forward in
the game and so she was able to you know
live it right there alongside me you
know from the other side of the earth
and know that I was succeeding yeah and
an incredible gifts her her decline only
began I mean no one knew that she would
pass away so soon and her decline only
began literally when final tribal
council ended in the same day the same
day that I was finishing the game she
was walking around the block and then
the game was over and you know she
started to let go a little bit but she
waited until I got home and it's just
she held on for you she
she and I absolutely did and I think
sharing your story and I know I
respected you too for for not using it
you know some people come on the show
and they're they're almost overly vocal
about their struggles in a way that
almost feels like a pitch because I know
what you I know what you were going
through
I am I lost my mother this year to
cancer and and I I know being in a
holding pattern like that is incredibly
difficult
yeah but to do it away from your family
and friends is next level strength
you must feel now having accomplished
this we have one survivor you've given
your mom an incredible gift
you must feel like you can do anything
now Adam you know she always instilled
that in me and I felt that when I went
out there you know I I was like III I'm
gonna play this game I want people to
underestimate me I want people to not
know how big of a fan of this game I
really am how smart I am you know that
and and and you know she instilled so
much confidence in me and my dad as well
and and yeah I definitely am looking
forward to you know the next stage of
life wherever it may take me but her her
energy will always be guiding me well
this next stage includes a little more
cash in the bank of Florida with partial
part of your money going to lung cancer
research good boy
what are you gonna do with the rest you
know I I work for a non-profit that's my
you know that's my career so I don't
necessarily make as much money as I
could potentially working in the
for-profit world so this money is gonna
allow me to continue to pursue my
passions and put my efforts towards
things that I think are you know
worthwhile for this world and so it's
gonna it's gonna stay pretty pretty you
know tied up there I'm not gonna be I'm
not a big consumer I'm not gonna be
buying any cars or any you know no I'm
not a big spenders Adam congratulations
once again from all of us in DT Canada
from the podcast Parvati wants to send
her congratulations you do thank you